Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought
to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact,
a bunch of my startups already use
Vimeo pro including wealth front,
who uses it to explain how
wealth front works task grab,
it uses it to tell their company's
story and there are many other names you
would recognize among their
customers, airbnb, Etsy, et
cetera. Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level
video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost. Features include gorgeous
high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of
video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and a
fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro, et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get
all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated
bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash
business that's vim,
e o.com forward slash business and
use Promo Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just
for you guys, so check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash
business promo code. Tim,
this episode is brought to you by
Athletic Greens. I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day, and you can get 50 oh my
gosh, 50% off. Yes, 50% off.
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward
slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim, check it out.
It's tasty, but more important,
it will help you not screw up when
you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me, it just covers the
basis, takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash tip
hello ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
each episode is my job to
deconstruct world class performers,
to tease out the habits,
routines, morning rituals,
favorite books, etc. That have made
them spectacularly good at what they do.
And there are patterns that
you notice across disciplines.
That is why I interview people from a
very broad spectrum of areas like the
military, entertainment, chest,
sports, comedy, et Cetera.
So it ranges from Arnold Schwarzenegger
to General Stanley McChrystal.
And in this episode we have a dynamic duo.
We have Seth Rogen at
Seth Rogen, R, O, g, e,
n who is an actor, writer, producer,
and director and his partner in crime,
Evan Goldberg at Evan
Goldberg on the twitters,
who is a Canadian director,
screenwriter and producer. Together,
they get into a whole lot of mischief
and create some amazing comedy,
and I had a chance to spend some time
with both of these great gents as well as
their team,
which is spectacular and I won't mention
the location in case they're keeping
that quiet,
but here's some background.
They've collaborated on
films such as Super Bad,
which they actually first
conceived of as teenagers,
knocked up pineapple express,
the Green Hornet and funny people.
They've also written for the
Ali g show and the Simpsons.
In 2013 evidence,
Seth released their directorial debut.
This is the end,
which was actually a combination of two
different ideas and we get into that in
the conversation in 2014 set to start in
and produced alongside Evan neighbors,
which was a worldwide comedy hit and
has taken in more than 268 million
worldwide and then appearing in
the news yet again in December,
2014 Rogan and Goldberg's film,
the interview became easily the most
talked about news story around the world
and that was not just in the
entertainment mags but in every different
publication because of many reasons.
So under extremely
difficult circumstances.
The film persevered to become
Sony Pictures, number one,
digital title of all time neighbors
too is shooting right now and will be
released next May. Seth and Evan are
also in production on sausage party,
which I saw a clip of a prelim clip,
which is a Raunchy animated movie
for adults about one sausage,
his quest to discover the truth about
his existence and I really hope to God
that some of the Raunchy or scenes make
it end because they will make your head
explode.
Seth and Evan are producing that film
with Megan Ellison and Conrad Vernon.
In our conversation,
the one you're about to listen to,
we discuss all manner of tactics and
silliness, including Kule, Cushing,
karate,
it's God empty hand and uh,
how they participated in that writer's
block and related debates. Does it exist?
Does not exist. How do you contend
with it if it does writing process? Uh,
I ask questions like, who are the most
underrated comedians and comedy writers?
What is the odd book that Judd
Apatow recommended to them,
which happens to also be
woody Allen's favorite.
How super bad got made after
the first drafted around age 13.
How kids in the hall influenced them,
the movie,
they both wish they'd
written common pot mistakes.
So if you're just listening to
this for a marijuana playbook,
well there might be something
in here for you as well.
So recommended newb pot for
working versus relaxing and much,
much more. So I really hope
you enjoy this. As always,
if you're not getting my five bullet
Friday newsletter check, checking out,
it is a very,
very popular,
it's just a short email with a lot of
tactical stuff gets sent out every Friday.
You can check that out for our
work week.com forward slash Friday.
That's all spelled out.
Four hour work week.com forward slash
Friday or just go to four hour work
week.com and enter your email there and
for all the show notes for this episode,
all the links,
et cetera.
I'm just going to four hour work
week.com and click on podcasts.
So without further ado,
please enjoy my conversation
with Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
Oven. Seth, look to the show.
Thank you. Thanks for having us.
I appreciate you guys taking the time,
especially in this very busy,
busy month that you gents have.
And a,
I thought we could start with a story
that we had discussed a little bit,
Evan in the car, which was
Kilkee shit. So tell me about
karate.
He goes [inaudible] we're
talking about when we were kids,
how uh,
how we behaved and how I was a softie.
And so I did rugby and karate to cut,
try and toughen myself up.
And I joined at the
Jewish community center,
which is one of the places that we
became really good friends. He said,
had been doing it a few years before me.
We'd already met him Bar Mitzvah class
and our parents were like a Jewish
community center that can't be much,
you know,
just simple karate and they let
us beat the living shit out of.
It was pretty, uh, I realize like we were,
the bad guys from karate
kid were a Cobra Kai. Yeah.
Like we were banned from
tournament and from tournaments.
And then we finally went to a tournament
and I realized that like the way they
taught us to fight like was not
conducive to tournament fighting.
And I punched the guy in the throat
and got disqualified from tournament
basically. And I didn't know that that
wasn't like what you were supposed to do.
I was just like,
oh,
he's supposed to beat the shit
out of this condition to respond.
I have a memory of one time where they
made me fight that like 35 year old and
when I was 14 and she liked choked me out
on the ground until I pass though this
was in class. I remember
fighting like full grown men too.
I remember hitting that guy rod so hard.
I rod was like a 280 pounds,
six foot three guy and he was like 1,440
and I hit him so hard in the face with
like a spinning backhand that he knocked
him in, like almost knocked him out.
It like dazed him completely
and then they let me,
they look clean,
let him fight me again.
Did he like punched me in the
mouth so hard? I like couldn't. Uh,
I couldn't like I think my mouth started
bleeding and then I heard and then,
but there's so many stories
that are flooding of the
day that ended it all where
I got kicked in the hip by a 40 year
old black belt who fractured my hip.
And then he backed up into a pillar and
got a piece of wood lodged in his foot
and thus ended RQ cause,
but I remember fighting with
teacher on the ground one time,
like the teacher Sean with like I
remember like grappling on the ground with
him. Ed like to the point where he
would just like do anything you can't.
And I was like trying to bite him.
I was like spitting on him and like that
was like what you were supposed to do
in the class. One time you did it, you
would get in trouble and he'd be like,
you could do more.
Like it wasn't time.
I spat in his face and then he took
the spit and the exact same thing,
exact same thing to me.
And we thought it was like this is what
[inaudible] Jewish community center
karate is. So you mentioned Gilks in,
you're like, I don't think, you know,
people get the wrong image when I tell
them karate and I from having lived in
Japan for a year as an exchange student
is first time I got exposed to kill Shin.
And those were like the bad boys of the
karate world. It was a very well known,
like you don't want to get the
leg kicks are very famous dude.
One time I got there,
the dentist, there's like
grown men.
This was child abuse.
Like this guy had the log gets legs and
be entirely these little brown slippers
and I uh,
and he just like kept kicking my legs
out from under me relentlessly and there
was nothing I can, he
may stop it. All of us,
they made all of us watch as he
did it to him for like, yeah,
just like I would get up putting it like
try to fight again and he would just
like smack my legs out from under me.
And just like,
I remember just hitting the ground.
There was this one guy,
the guy who ended up fracturing my hip,
which ruined my rugby and karate actually
in your hip is not a small hairline
fracture.
It wasn't terrible,
but it's enough that I couldn't
run and stuff like that. Uh,
Malcolm and he would do
this thing to this day.
I can't comprehend how he did it in
a movie. You wouldn't believe it.
He literally like casually
put both hands behind.
His back in a small room was try and
hit me and I couldn't and I'm like 15,
16 real fit.
I've been doing karate for like five
years and I couldn't even touch him.
I remember Malcolm kicked me in the
eye once so hard that my parents,
I had to call their family friends who
were eye doctors and take me to their
house after the karate class cause I like
couldn't see out of one of my eyes for
like three hours. But I regret nothing.
I regret nothing either. It's weird.
It's weird down cause I'm so I thought
it was always like not a violent person
but I'm not competitive and I don't like
care about any of that stuff that much.
So it did it,
did it turn you guys off of that
type of thing sort of indefinitely?
How that point or certainly as somebody
who has like Tmj and like has had some
joint issues,
I can identify that that is too brutal.
Like their knuckles were all puffed up
and because we would break boards and if
you didn't break the board you
had to try it again. I'm like,
can I split a knuckle into
sounds like a liability.
It's weird because it was happening
to get the Jewish community center and
that's what's so strange about it.
And then rent like it had,
I don't think any of our parents by
parents would come and watch some time,
but they thought, I guess I hope
to get to 100 frame of reference.
Maybe something just felt like,
oh,
that's what crummy classes because he
just picked me up and like not comment
that I was bleeding from.
My parents would come sometimes cause I
started when I was younger so they like
knew I did it for like over getting for
10 years or something like [inaudible]
seven and you did it three? Yeah,
I think I started, we did it
with our buddy,
uh,
Fogle and our buddy Corbyn or buddy
Glassberg and they would just make us as
friends, beat the shit out of each
other. It was pretty, Glassberg was soft.
He was there.
He got to play the younger guys,
which made them probably feel pretty good.
When did you guys first meet?
I mean first encounter each other?
Uh, it was, I was going to,
I went to like two hours of
afterschool Hebrew school Tuesday,
Thursday and he went to like a half
Hebrew school, half normal school.
He was a pretty much like,
it was like a Hebrew school.
It was like they did
half and half studies,
but it was like full on
like Jewish elements.
And he would get out when I would go in
and I took the class at the synagogue,
which was beside his school. Right.
So we would see each other for years.
We didn't really know each other,
but we would see each other and I was
kinda like the loudest person from this
side and he was friends with full
role. Uh, I became, well yet this guy,
Sammy Fogel,
who is the [inaudible] of super bad,
but he's not really that big of
a loser. We just met him. Uh,
he and I became good friends and sets
mother and his mother were good friends
and then it all kind of
culminated to bar Mitzvah class.
We all took Sunday morning,
what was it called?
Post to fill holes and to fill in class
where they would give us chocolate milk
and bagels to lure us to learn how to do
our bar Mitzvah portion is departments
for class if you gave me,
yeah, I know it's a weird
mix, but it's delicious and a,
and we just kind of met there and
because of Fogel we became friends. Yeah.
And when did you guys start
collaborating creatively?
In hindsight, like eight months later.
How old were you guys? Around? 13, 12,
13. It was literally, it's not
like we pretend we don't remember.
We don't remember,
but we were watching some crappy movie
and we just looked at each other and
we're like, we could write a better
movie. And then there's like a pause.
It's like we should write a better mood.
And I think I would use stand
up already at that point.
And so like there was
some context for like,
we can write things and they'll become
things like I was already like writing
things and then performing
them. So, um, it wasn't,
it wasn't just like two, like we
actually like wanted to make a movie,
like it wasn't him. And then
I'd already seen like, oh,
you can tangibly like do something.
And a lot of people, uh, you know,
I call you came all the way from
Canada and, and, and it's not like,
like Vancouver is a movie town
going to movies at our high school,
like almost anyone that we
know in America is from.
And they all think we're like bumpkins
real city where they made tons of movies.
And so you would see movie sets everywhere
growing up. And our high school,
they shot a lot of movies and Diamond
Phillips Movie Masterminds starring
Patrick Stewart and Vincent, Carl
Pfizer. Uh, it's not a fantastic movie,
but it was shot at our
high school. And, um,
and so you would see it around. And
so it was like, it was Kinda like, no,
we didn't know anyone in the business or
anything like that or who was involved
in movies. But, um, it was just
like around, and so you kind of,
my first interaction with our friend
Amelia Wasserman's mother, uh,
produced like kiddish
kids shows and she like,
let me try to write some kids episodes
and gave me some point and I think Julia
Martinez, his dad, like produce TV shows
or something like that. I can't remember.
Like, we knew people whose parents
had like kind of like, you know, uh,
jobs and like it was around,
it was just kind of around
this girl I dated Abby Salzburg.
Her mother was a writer for the newspaper
and she kind of gave me some pointers
and helped me out. So we had like some
help, but we didn't really have a hard in.
I think one of my distant, distant
cousins was a producer on passenger 57.
The Wesley Snipes.
Yeah,
I that I remember hearing as a child,
it's really fascinating that you say
you're given the opportunity to kind of
tinker in the writing perspective
with, uh, with these episodes.
When I grew up next to the,
uh,
the gent who created the choose your
own adventure book series. What's, yeah,
that's awesome. So we had my brother and
I had chances to test drive his books,
provide feedback, and this is a
bad choice. He gave him feedback,
ended up using, he would put our names
into the books. If you go back there,
a handful of books,
books and yeah, that was,
they were a power couple of his
friends was walking through the woods.
[inaudible] he was warning
the mountains are dangerous.
And you guys, is it true that you started
working on super bad around that time?
And we started writing.
We sat down
and started that. That was the first
thing we ever tried to do was writing.
She was writing Superman and it was,
it was terrible at first,
but it was really bad at first.
But, um, but that being said,
we liked movies so much and we're so
into movies that like looking back,
we kind of instinctually like understood
the vague structure of movies in like a
pretty instinctual way.
And like we loved bad movies, which I
think actually was extremely beneficial.
What not to do.
Tons of B movie was this place called
Video Matika. Is that what it's called?
There were seven movies for $7
for seven days. It was correct.
And we would go and do that and
watch them all. And it was, you know,
get like two good movies in five crappy.
But then around this time was when movies
like pulp fiction and clerks and like
that, like, like a Rushmore
and a bottle rocket.
Like it was kind of like the dawn
of like nineties independent cinema.
And we were really, really
into those movies too. And
again, a lot of those movies,
you know, uh, at least
in theory had to care.
And the myth had kind of
like a do it yourself feel.
We're like Kevin Smith
just make clerks clearly.
Like they just got a camera and just
made a bunch of friends were like,
let's fucking do this. Did. And that
was very like inspirational to us, uh,
because it just seemed very
achievable, you know? Um,
and so I think that's one of the
reasons we again started doing it.
It was just like, we're like,
it was about high school kids.
We knew high school kids,
I want it to be an actor.
We knew there was other kids in our
school who were trying to be actors and
stuff like that.
And so it just kind of seemed like we,
like if we write a high school movie,
we could make a high school
movie basically. Yeah. And
he had his standup start.
And uh, for me it was like,
when I was like five years old,
if he asked me what I wanted
to do was be a writer,
I always want it to be a writer.
They actually tried to send
me to a psychiatrist in
elementary school because I
would write like dark stuff.
Cause my Hebrew school,
I learned about the Holocaust and I kept
writing about the Holocaust and they
thought there was something wrong with me.
But I remember we met when he was like
the first person I ever met who like
wrote recreationally other than me.
Like I wrote stand up and he wrote
like stories and stuff like that.
And I remember like when
you're like a 13 year old kids
eat a lot of other 13
year old kid who's like,
what are their hobbies is writing
recreationally. It's not that common.
And so he kind of made me realize
what the standup, he was like,
like he just did it. And so we both
were like, what if we just did this? Uh,
no one at this age is trying to do it. So
if we get a jump on it, maybe we'll do.
Okay. And also it seems like the
easiest path to becoming a writer.
Like I tried to write a novel once
and I failed. It is really hot.
Those are hard. Yeah. And you just funny
you mentioned the school psychologist.
So I was sent to the school psychologist.
Also everyone in this room,
I was for sure
the writing assignments
I didn't want to do.
And so thematically I would turn them
into stories about serial killers.
I think it's a common reaction,
dystopian future story about a bunch of
kids trying to get out of a Nazi control
future. And it ended with all of them
dying. You invented the young adult novel,
you invented divergent
and the hunger games.
The reason they tried to send me
to drink is because I drew the
picture of all their
ups is at the end.
That's a,
that's a nice touch for those people
who wouldn't take the time to read it.
You've got to really spell it out.
So what was,
what was the difference before you set
then in the early days, uh, between,
what were the biggest differences
between writing for standup?
And this can be contemporary like in
general and writing for film for instance.
Um,
I,
I've thought about it a lot and when we
started writing movies I honestly like,
and,
and when we started doing it more,
I kind of became less
interested in writing stand
up in some ways because like,
and I honestly think that good stand up,
I wasn't the best stand up comedian is one
thing. Like I would, I was pretty good.
I was like a B plus standup comedian,
a minus.
I wasn't like an a plus 10 and comedian
and I'm not saying that we're like the
best script writers in the world,
but we've achieved a plus
moments I think here and there.
And so that, that was one of the
things I was just like aware of.
I would just like watch other
people do it and be like, wow,
this guy's like doing something like that.
I like here, they're just better at it,
you know? And when we started writing
movies, I started to feel like, oh,
like we act like this.
I feel like we could maybe again like
really carve out our own niche doing,
which I didn't feel like I was
particularly doing, doing standup.
I was young and that was at first and
each is like I would write about my young
person's experience,
but then as I got older I found like,
I don't know as a standup I was
struggling a little bit to find a unique
perspective. I have a theory you
cease to be tortured. Yeah, exactly.
That was part of it. I was like
really tortured when I was, I mean,
I mean I wasn't that not really tortured
like you know, young neuro seasoning.
I'll stand standup
comics function largely.
Not all of them but a lot of them on
anxiety. Like self obsessed that much.
Yeah. I don't find myself
that interesting. Honestly.
One of the other things is like I,
and I think writing,
and that's one of the reasons
I think writing movies was,
was better is because I was writing other
people and I also struggled with stand
up is that you could only really,
and again good standups do this,
but I couldn't find a way to do it is
like I can only talk from one perspective
in Standup,
but in a movie you can write two or
three or four or five or six perspectives
all in one scene. You could have five
guys arguing there about how to, you know,
turn it, you know, how to
do anything, what's the best
way to get out of this room,
you know, and to, and as we
started writing, like, you know,
some of the best scenes that we've
ever achieved are literally just people
screaming at each other.
And so like I think that was something
that I thought was very funny that we
were good at was like conflict.
And it's hard to have like
conflict in stand up comedy for me,
I couldn't find a way to do it.
Other people do it and they tell
stories that involve conflict.
And the whole thing is about,
you know, the struggle.
And I look at it now and sometimes I
think like, man, if I kept doing it,
I maybe would have broken
through a wall. But, um, I just,
I dunno. And I loved movies. That was
the other thing is just like, and I,
I loved movies also,
but I was a bit more of a comic nerd.
He was a comic nerd too, but I was like
extreme comic meaning comic book. Yeah.
My brother is a natural speed reader.
He reads it at a remarkable pace.
He can read a book in a day, like a
400 page book, just burn through it.
So he would read comics and mountains of
them would form and then he would draw
them. So I would mimic him cause he was
two years older and I would read all the
comics he read and then try to draw
like him. He's actually an expert.
He's a very good artist.
He drew all the penises for Superbad.
[inaudible]
make a cameo in the big Lebowski
and he's a lawyer now. But, uh,
I tried to like mimic
him with that stuff and,
and comics are just movie
storyboards there isn't mad again.
And I read all the comic books too.
I think that's it.
I mean it's like we connected
heavily over Calvin and Hobbes. Yeah.
We love artists of all time.
The sarcasm of it,
like forged our own genius. But I
think we just liked like the cinematic,
like again, comics and like it just seemed
appealing. Um, and again, I think, yeah,
and it's funny that at the time,
like,
like if you look at what we've done
recently, like we like grandiose things,
we like big things to happen,
end of the world scenarios and all that.
But at the time, all we knew was
that we really wanted to get laid.
We weren't getting laid
and we weren't super cool.
And I think the reason Superbad worked
out is it's rare that you are the thing
you're writing on at the moment. You're
doing it and you're self aware of it.
And we're still, I mean,
and that's something that
we've continued to try to do,
honestly. I mean neighbors, you
know, it was a very good example.
All my friends are having,
our friends are having kids or trying
to have kids and are married and her
getting older and are moving
into different places. And like,
I don't have a kid and I want to go out
and I call all my friends and none of
them can that they had. So
I think from the get go, um,
and that's something that
came from stand up comedy.
Like there's a comic named Darryl Lennox
who still performs, um, who is great.
And He, the comics were very nice to
me, which is in retrospect, insane.
Cause I would not be nice to like a 13
year old kid who was doing standup comedy.
I don't think. Maybe I would,
but I don't assume I would.
But I remember he saw me perform
and I used to have like jokes.
I would try to like mimic other
comedians like Steven writers, Seinfeld,
like what's the deal with crazy glue?
And he was like, he was like, dude,
you're like the only 14 year old.
He's like,
you're the only person here who could
like talk about trying to get like a hand
job for the first time.
Talk about that. Like,
that is like so much more interesting
than anything you're talking about. Like,
why are you just talking about that?
And I was like, oh, you're right.
That's actually a very
good way of doing it.
And then that kind of
carried through everything.
Yeah. And uh, it, it's, it's, um,
I've been really fascinated just sort
of observing you guys work and, uh,
you know,
realizing that at least for me,
when you get started super
bad at a time when those, uh,
all those feelings were very kind
of ever present in your lives.
And when I look back and say, pass
books, people have asked me like,
what would you edit?
What would you change?
And I don't want to touch it because
I feel like it was written at a very
precise point in time related to very
specific pains that I might not be
experiencing now because it's a, you
know, the chapters passed on. What, uh,
what does your writing
process look like now?
A lot of people have asked me to ask you
both this, uh, but what is just from the,
the very first sort of
concept stages? Well, uh,
as I was telling you earlier,
it's changed a little.
We just did this project preacher with
a guy named Sam Catlin chasing bad and,
and we used to immediately
start like kind of we,
we would always write down ideas and he
taught us this new trick of not writing
down ideas for a good month and just talk,
shooting it around and talking and talking
and talking. And I kept saying, look,
now we're going to write.
Right? And he was like, no,
no, no. We just keep talking.
And that's a new trick
that I think was great.
Just spend way more time
talking to you about it.
That's what he said in breaking bad.
They would do is just like,
before they did anything,
they would just talk and talk and talk.
And it's something as you look, we did
an undeclared. When I look back at it,
it's like we're just anxious
to get going I think sometimes.
But I feel like now,
I mean,
and it's kind of always been this way in
that like we'll come up with ideas and
it's like sometimes it's like there's
almost like a Darwinistic process food a
year later or so.
Like if it's something we're still
talking about sometimes years later,
there's some, I mean like there's this
movie that we're talking about writing.
I was going through old files,
like the first one from like 2011 or
something like that. Tangible example is,
this is the end.
We had two separate ideas.
One was a movie about the apocalypse
and another one was celebrities playing
themselves in a disaster type scenario.
Both of those ideas that survived
for four, five years and they slowly,
we realized if we merge these things,
it's going to be a good synthesis. And uh,
and that, that's the perfect
example. Like we, we, we, you know,
we'd just be sitting around working
on whatever and it'd be like,
what about that apocalypse? Or it's just
what we talk about. Like, I mean, it's,
it's like,
you know,
we like what we do and it's fun for us
to think about it so organically we'd
just be sitting there doing
something else. And that's the thing.
We would just start joking around about,
you know? And then if it sticks around,
then it at least means that we like,
it isn't, I like, like, like, like,
like lately I've been obsessed with
artificial intelligence and we're not
writing anything about that.
But in a year from now,
if I'm still talking about it,
maybe it'll happen.
So when you have something that's really
persistent like that, and you have,
say the celebrities playing,
playing themselves and the end of
the world and you're like, you know,
this could be really interesting if we
combine these two things at the time. Uh,
not necessarily now that you have the
input from the breaking bad writer on that
approach, but what were the next steps
you guys took once you were like,
you know what, let's, let's try
to pull the trigger on this.
Well, we, it took us a really long time
to figure out how to do it. Honestly,
that was one of those
movies were bizarrely,
it just took us like we could
think of the first three,
two acts of the movie and then we
couldn't figure out how to end the movie.
And it little joke was like a year and
a half I think until we thought of the
idea that they realize they can
still redeem themselves basically,
which is what allows
the third act to happen,
which is they're all starting
trying to redeem themselves and,
and we just didn't think of that and it
was literally just like we couldn't do
it. I mean, while we're working
on other stuff and doing it,
it's not like we're just sitting
in a room for a year and a half,
like bang our heads against the wall.
It's like we're still doing things.
But that if like,
I mean in that example it literally just
took us a really long time to come up
with the idea that allowed the movie to,
to function.
And then once we thought of that idea,
I remember we wrote the first draft of
this in the end and like nine days or
something like that. That was all
three acts or just set the whole,
we wrote the home movie like the
whole first, the hundred and 20 pages.
We wrote the whole script. We Sat,
we had an extensive outline. Yeah,
because we'd been kicking it around
for years. And like one thing we do,
a lot of our movies are kind of
genre based, especially lately,
you know Pineapple Express and this is
the end and the interview to some degree.
And so something we do is just
watch tons of movies in that genre.
And so like with this the end,
we just watched tons of these like
horror movies and apocalypse movies and
movies about isolation and kind of grew
little groups of people that are stuck
together. And as we do that, we just are
joking around and coming up with ideas.
Oh it wouldn't be funny if we, we
send a guy out on a rope, it's like,
oh they need water. And then you just kind
of pick up these themes in the movies.
Like when Craig Robinson went out of the
house with a rope that was based off of
the mist. Exactly. And part of it, I mean,
and we talk a lot about of it is like
really trying to like have our cake and
eat it too.
In these movies like it,
it's like we are kind of like mocking
the genres as we were trying to
participate in the full heart fully,
you know?
And in doing that we'd like to,
it's almost like the characters in the
movie are aware of the same cultural
references that we are.
And so it would stand to believe that
all that stuff would be on the table
basically.
And so,
so that's a big part of the process
is just lists of ideas. Tons of ideas.
Jonah gets possessed, someone
gets puked on, they need water,
someone steals the water, someone doesn't
like the rules. They try to make rules.
How do they split up the
food and something like, oop,
just at this into like a notebook or
do you put it into a word document?
It's just a,
it's just a running list.
There's yelling right now with the latest
idea we're messing about with like a
10 page.
We have like a 10 page lists and I
think there's another 10 pages this week
literally. And it's like, it's
like a relationship type movie.
So there's like I do, it's just like
things happen to us. It was just like,
oh a fight about this
husband who holds back, wife,
wife who enhances husbands positive.
And then it's just like,
it's also just like house warming party.
Like it's things like that and like,
or we'll go to a party and something
funny will happen and you put that in.
So it's just a stream of consciousness
collection and, and again and like,
and like the ideas themselves.
As you go through these lists over
and over throughout the years,
some ideas you kind of stick in your
head and you remember and some start to
seem stupid and you start to create
characters kind of based on the ideas are
sometimes you call with the characters
first and sometimes you'll just meet
someone and you'll be
like someone like that,
someone who is going through this in
life for, you know what I mean? Um,
and it can come from anywhere.
And then for a while we got really uh,
uh,
and then process wise I think we
kind of strayed a little bit in that.
We got so busy,
we started kind of like farming it
out just a little bit to other people,
which is something that we're
kind of trying to not do is
do a lot of stuff.
And so we had other people writing stuff
for us and it all worked out very well,
but we got it.
I think literally at the end of the
day if like the thing we are best at is
actually writing and,
and I think we kind of stopped doing that
honestly for awhile in Lou we got to,
we got the opportunity to become directors
and that was so exciting that we just
want it to direct another one and then
we'd go home and we will be coming
producers as well which and like, and it
was all kind of, it wasn't like a plan.
It was a very organic thing
that was happening as our
careers we're building and
expanding in a different directions.
But that was happening looking back,
uh,
our writing,
which is probably the thing we're best
at got kind of pushed to the side a
little bit,
but now that we've done I think a pretty
okay job setting up these other things
are producing is going very well or
directing, you know, is established.
And so I think we can refocus on writing
things and kind of settled back into
what we were doing really exciting too
because the producing and the directing
caused this cycle where it was like,
we got to get another one out because we
need to, you know, you direct one movie,
you're not really a director until they
can drink like two or three things and
then they're like, oh, this
guy's not going anywhere.
But now that we've
gotten past that hurdle,
we can go back to what we really liked,
which is writing things and not rushing.
Yeah, exactly. How did the first
script you guys collaborated on, uh,
that got sold or got made a
cross that chasm Superbad yeah,
it took 10 years and years and years.
Basically I moved to La to do
freaks and Geeks, um, when I was 17.
Just a quick interjection then.
Why did they do a casting call?
It was at your high school? No, it was um,
or they went to Vancouver sometimes on,
um,
based in La. It was, it was, it was based,
it was set in Michigan. It was shot in La.
But sometimes, uh, Judd and
Paul Judd Apatow and Paul Feig,
the Creator and Paul
the Creator and judge,
the executive producer of
freaks and geeks. It had a very,
they wanted very real kits and they had
an idea from the beginning that they
wouldn't find them in
that if you're in La,
you're like an actor kid and that there's
a good chance that you are not what
they're looking for. That
being said, I think they cast,
I think everyone but me and
one other guy out of la,
but so they were kind of wrong but
thank God they looked at least because,
so what they did is they did casting
calls of Vancouver and Boston and New York
and Chicago and Toronto and all these
cities and I got to audition in May Coover
and they were there like Paul and
Judd, like we're in Vancouver. Yeah.
They were like in the room and I recognize
Paul Feig cause he's in this movie a
ski patrol, which I had seen
Jason's keep control. And so, uh,
see the topless woman,
no
pervy version of Ski School Ski
Patrol's not that pervy this may be one.
And that's why I was sort of it it,
yeah, it's not, it's not ski school. Um,
but that threw me anyway. Um, and so yeah.
And so they cast me from Vancouver and
I moved to l w I went there and shot the
pilot and then I came back and
then it got picked up and then I'm,
and so I was very lucky cause I
like moved to La like with a job.
Like I wasn't like one of,
I didn't have to like go to La and
like try to find work for myself.
Like I went there employed,
which was like, I,
at the time I didn't realize like
how many massive hurdles when it was
overcoming just by doing that,
you know what I mean? Um,
and then so I was there and then meanwhile
we're writing super bad and I give it
to Judd and Judd Judd was very
busy at the time running the show,
which was like going down in flames
basically, even though it was very good.
And so he kind of didn't pay too much
attention to it at first. But Jake Kasdan,
who was one of the directors of the
show, um, who has gone on to direct,
uh, tons of movies and stuff like that,
he directed the pilot of freaks and Geeks.
He, um, he really, he's
just like a very nice guy.
He was around,
he was in his twenties.
He's very young and so he just like
really took a lot of time to like sit with
me and talk to me about it. He
would give us notes on it. And like,
it was just very encouraging
because he was like,
this is good and you can keep working
on this. And I was just at university
see it at McGill in Montreal a little
time because I couldn't come to America
even if I wanted to, cause I didn't have
a visa. His Dad's American dads in there,
but I wanted to be a writer and it
seemed like via him on freaks and Geeks,
we had an inlet. So I studied us history,
so I knew who I was writing for. Right.
Yeah. Good idea. I loved history and
I thought if I understood America,
it gets better.
I could write better for Americans because
I knew that I knew Canadians. And uh,
and America is quite different.
Yeah.
But then after at some point,
jug did read it and it was,
um,
during the show we did a undeclared.
So freaking he's got canceled.
And then because Judd read super bad,
he got another show going the
next year called undeclared,
which was about college freshmen.
I was literally the exact age
of a college freshman. And so,
and he liked how super bad was written,
so he hired me as a writer on the show.
And so, and then juring on
declared he really like,
took,
uh,
like a produce oriel role on Superbad and
we'd give us tons of notes and try to,
and that's when we first started
going around trying to sell it.
That was in like 2000,
2001. And then 2002. Yeah.
He said,
bring your friend on down.
I'll,
I'll throw him a tiny bit of cash so
he can live and you guys should try to
write something else.
So I came down and we spent two
months writing Pineapple Express,
which he told us to come up with a
hundred ideas for movies, which is insane.
We got to 50 which is great. We
never made any of them. And then, uh,
and then he was like,
these are awesome,
but you should instead write a movie
about a pothead who's a process server who
gets hunted by his own dealer.
And we said that's stupid and that will
end your career before it ever happened
to be like a modern Cheech and
Chong. And he just said, ah,
but what if it was good?
Yeah. We were like, oh
what if it was good?
We love action movies and you know,
die hard and lethal weapon.
And they were like,
oh what if we kind of make it like a
nineties like these nine these action
movies that we love so much.
And so we wrote pineapple trust pretty
like we just loved it. It wasn't,
we started doing, we really well
[inaudible] ourselves in the morning,
like maybe like six weeks
or something like that.
It was like one of those things where
like wake up at 3:00 PM until 6:00 AM we
were very unhealthy at
this time in our lives.
This was that the time when we got a
Costco card and gained like 20 pounds
reading seafood get passed in
cheese because it was cheap
all day long. It was gross. So,
so by the end of,
I think like 2002 both pineapple express
and super bad were written and just no
one wanted to make them. And it would,
it would come close, it'd be someone, oh,
we might make it and then it
wouldn't happen. And we might make,
and every now and then,
and like I didn't have the money to do it.
I would fly down,
we would go and pitch it,
or my dad would drive with me from
Vancouver and we'd go and pitch it.
And every time we pitched it,
probably 10 times,
Judd and Seth and me would go and my
dad would drop me off and we'd go in and
they'd be like, we love this, this
is great. And we're like, okay,
so you're gonna make it. And
they're like, oh no, we can't.
And I was supposed to play the Seth role.
And slowly throughout this process,
like I just, I still remember the
meeting where like always I was like,
I'm going to place that. And that I
remember like it took so many years,
there was like what BD rose like,
I think this was the meeting where I
no longer should say that I'm going to
place that cause I'm 23 years old.
So we uh, these were studio heads
or studio exactly what it was.
It was,
it was some new companies with like weird
money that comes from who knows where
it was some studios, it was like
every type of thing you could imagine.
Basically when did the, instead of
the other shoe drop in the positive.
So meanwhile like we start getting work,
we get hired on the leg show,
which is great. Um, and it's just, it,
it starts to make things
like pick up a little for us.
I was in the 40 year old virgin,
like things like that started to happen
and while he was doing 40 old virgin
just invited me to
participate in some capacity,
but I knew I had to finish my degree
so I could actually stay legally.
So I finished my degree in,
missed out on that.
And by the time I came down the premiere,
it happened and the movie had hit. Yeah.
And so Judd started to become
a successful movie person. Um,
like a,
it was now a director and writer and a
producer and incredibly successful one.
So, uh, an increment had
come out and done well,
which he was a producer on and then
Talladega nights came out and did really
well.
And I think it was wait,
Talladega nights didn't come
up before we made knocked up.
They made knocked up first,
didn't we? We did. I don't
know.
I don't think so.
I remember going with Judd
to the Deville Film Festival,
I think for 40 year old virgin
while he was here in Atlanta.
I think shooting Talladega Nights,
I'm bad with years in time.
But this was approximately,
you would have happened.
And then around now it's like,
you know when you get
successful like Judd was,
people just start wanting
whatever you have.
And so it was Sony was just like,
we'll make stuff and so they Superbad
and then at the time to make an a however
much it was like 22 million like it
was, uh, it was, it was a
bizarre model that had never
been done. No famous people,
low budget.
It was kind of an experiment in the
studio was doing to see if they could make
big movies at a smaller budget
without famous pan. They also, pun,
what's crazy is knocked up
pineapple express and super bad.
We're all made in like one year I think
basically like we made them like back to
back to back because that
it was essentially like once
the flood opened we just
like shoved everything
in there that we like.
If you just look at like statistically
we're going to be done in two years. Yeah,
exactly.
So you have to take advantage of the
way everything and and then and then
knocked up and knocked up and sue bag
came out the same summer in both did
really,
really well.
And so he was a coproducer on 40 old
virgin and they made him an IEP on,
knocked up and judge just made
me an e p two which was bonkers.
And I remember on the third day,
Evan's first day on set,
he was an executive producer
[inaudible] universal studios.
I remember
really hard cause I was like,
can I just take however
much water I want again man,
you can have all the water you want.
And I was like, what about the coffee
cups of coffee a day? And I remember I
saw Katherine Heigl and I was like, Hey,
what's up? We've been working
together for like a week.
And then she went up to
set and it was like, wow,
that guy has got a lot of energy.
He's got great.
He was like,
oh this is his first week
on the moon reaction.
Evan, when you first found out the
sewer bad was going to get made.
I mean it was that, I mean I assume
I freaked out and lost my mind. Uh,
I don't remember. Or was it not
such a blur? Because as he said,
it all went down in one year.
It was just the most exciting year ever.
But also for me, like he'd been working,
yeah, I've been going to school. Right.
Which meant not going to
school and getting drunk and
hanging out with friends.
Like I barely went to class,
so I had this shocking shift from like
slackers student to working 14 hours a
day.
And I remember I would have to sneak
away and just like go into a bathroom and
sleep for like 20 minutes because I
wasn't used to it. I couldn't handle it.
That's why I'm drinking so much coffee.
It was a really hard transition for me,
but knocked up was kind of like
boot camp because you know,
it was his big shot to make
something really huge for sure.
So we would go 16 hours,
17 hours, 14 hours days,
and I almost lost my mind.
But by the end of it,
I think I was like Kinda a battle hardened
to ride, get a condition for it all.
And what,
what were some of the,
the lessons that you guys learned have
learned from Judd? I mean, what are the,
some of the takeaways for whether
it's the creative process or, so
that's a, that's a whole
other, we could fail. The
biggest thing we learned from him,
in my opinion, he's like, and,
and we talked about this earlier,
is don't keep stuff to yourself.
Like when you're
surrounded by smart people,
bring them in and get other people's
opinions to share it with them.
And most importantly, emotion is what
matters. It's an emotional journey.
It doesn't matter if the aircraft carrier
hits the skyscraper in a collapses
onto the hero.
It's what is he feeling when that happens
and why does it matter that he has to
get out of the rubble?
He just taught us like emotion is the key.
Like the 40 old virgin is a
crazy, weird movie. It's insane.
But it's about a guy who's got
like a wound that he wants to heal.
And through this journey. He does.
And it's, it's all about that.
You mentioned that to me in every,
every character has to have a
wound that's a big Jug Judaism.
Yeah. I think I mean about the process.
I mean he basically like, yeah,
like taught us the process
that we use a lot. I mean,
especially in regards to collaboration and
[inaudible] he was somewhat
revolutionary in, in, in how he did it.
Like people had done it before,
like a Christopher guest and other people.
But Judd figured out a way to make improv
and mainstream movies collide in a way
that I don't think anything,
no one was really doing it like that.
And yeah,
I mean the filming process
itself, um, and how,
how to work on set is something that he
thought was a lot about. I mean, again,
it's all, it was Tufts that was
partially figured out together,
but he worked for years and
years and years before us.
And I mean, it's so funny.
It often, I remember one time we were
filming a scene and knocked up I think,
and improvising and he's,
or maybe it was even 40 old virgin,
the direction he screamed at us,
cause he screams direction from
another room a lot, which is hilarious.
But when he screamed at us was less semen,
more emotion.
And I think like that is
actually like across the board.
Good note to apply.
[inaudible]
yeah. But, uh, I think it was
just the area we were riffing on,
but I think, uh, yeah, I mean what
happened was saying exactly right,
like the emotional core. Like what,
what does it really you about? Like, um,
and,
and that the movies and then,
and that movies can be very
sweet and still like, uh,
and especially if you're good at make
a movie that is so like, you know,
I'm dirty or aggressively,
you know, um, you know, uh,
filled with profanity
and that thing that like,
it helps if they're sweet
and if you really like,
if they're not mean spirited and if you,
uh, and, and, and write what, you know,
it was a big thing and try to inject your
own like honesty and experiences into
your work,
even if it's a weird spy movie or end.
It is just about Jay and Seth and Jay
is upset that Seth has found new friends
and Seth is upset that Jay seems
to be holding onto the past.
That's what the movie's about. It has
nothing to do with the apocalypse really.
That's just the,
the,
the area at all went down in when
looking at filmmaking or comedy movies
specifically,
if you guys could have written something
that someone else wrote and besides
your own stuff where you're like,
ah,
adaptation adaptation, it's
the best. It's the best movie.
It's a masterpiece and the
script is even better than
the a movie. I think they made the
right choice with the changes they made.
But the script is just unreal.
That's like one of those,
not a lot of movies
making like mind blowing.
We jealous when I saw
that I was just like,
like five of my best
ideas. Like I was like, oh,
there should be a movie with someone who
has anxiety represented by a character.
And I was like, oh, he did this
10 times better than I ever could,
plus 10 other things
that I had as a whole.
And the mood is like funny and awesome.
And like it's just the story of how
that came together. Also in terms,
yeah. That he was hired to write bad
uptake, freaked out and it could do it.
It's like,
it's metal
backstory is, is so funny. And
then I would say on the flip side,
to me the most magical, uh, emotional
beautiful movies, the princess bride,
my favorite. Yeah. It's just,
I can't watch it too much.
That was, uh, you know,
I've had this fascination of screenwriting
even though I haven't pulled the
trigger on anything, but the,
the screenplay that the did,
it was the princess bride reading.
Uh,
William Goldman had the book on it. So
good. It's a great, all the backstory.
It's the one of the scenes in
adaptation because you mentioned it.
One of my favorite scenes is when he's
sitting in the movie Nicholas Cage,
sitting in his apartment at
this typewriter and he's like,
[inaudible] you hear me?
Internal dialogue.
So hungry,
like I need some coffee.
What are, what are your
opinions of writer's block? Oh,
ah, we touched on this earlier.
I think writer's block is complete
bullshit legion. Is it? Yeah,
sure.
I have it right now.
Like it's a term people give to a
bad week. Like I have bad weeks.
I don't have writer's block. Writer's
block implies that like you can't do it.
Some things are just
harder than other things.
Like you could have said that
we had writer's block on.
This is the end when we couldn't
figure out the third act.
I don't call that writer's block.
I say that was the biggest struggle
that we just have never experienced it.
Uh,
which is why you don't think it exists.
But I think that like you think that
we've never said no way. I imagine,
I think what I think what
happens to people actually,
and we're just lucky that
we haven't experienced it,
is they become uninspired like that
I think is what writer's block is.
And we're just lucky because
that has never happened to us.
I take issue with the term,
especially block writers,
difficulties writers
struggle with writer's cramp.
Writer's block implies like
it's just not going to happen.
But I think if you truly
lose your inspiration or your
who you are as a creative
person, I think people experience
those moments. And that's right here.
I think that's what writer's block.
What would you attribute that to?
Do you think that's because you guys
are writing what you know or what is,
yeah,
this
is not doing great.
The other one can pick up the
weight when one of us is uninspired.
The other one could be like
by Romans where I'm just like,
I don't even know what the fuck we're
doing anymore. Why are we doing this?
And then he'll just have an idea
and I have to just keep going.
And then you plow through and there's
probably moments he's thinking the similar
thing and I'm,
and in that moment I'm not thinking that.
And so it allows us to keep
going. But there's, there's,
there's a beauty to writing stuff on
your own. But specifically for movies,
I think writing as a team is extremely
beneficial. Even if you do write alone,
you should be sharing what you're
writing with everyone all the time,
all the time.
Because writer's block as some call it,
and I would rather not easily be solved
by just getting someone to help you.
Right. And I think a lot of writers, uh,
the biggest problem I think
writers have is they're like,
I can't show people until it's ready. And
that's poppy. You show it immediately.
I think if you just talk
about your ideas are like,
and I think that's how if
you have writer's block
that like there's probably a
reason you have it,
there's probably a reason
you're uninspired and that
is the thing you should be
writing about.
Like I think and I think in
order to arrive at that you
need to talk to someone.
Sometimes it's like,
and I think that's why it's helpful to
have another person is like we're very
open with each other.
We talk about pretty much everything
that's happening in our lives with one
another.
And so it's not like I'd just be sitting
there grumpy and he's like gotten an is
like no, not, not feeling it
today. Like, like we would,
I would explain why and
that would probably,
we do an idea because we
like to write them that way.
That's why it to both of us adaptations,
the most genius thing ever. Cause a guy,
it's a movie about writers took
writer's block and made it something.
And I guess that's my beef with
writer's block is like that's,
it's just something stopping
you, but it'll put you in
another direction. So it's,
it's still the path you're taking. Who,
who in your mind, whether right now,
you know,
alive or dead or the most,
some of the more underrated
comedy writers will,
Hannibal Burress is a standup comic.
He's not a writer,
but that man is a unspeakable genius.
Hannibal burse, Burris, Burris, he,
uh, he started this whole
bill Cosby thing and yeah,
if you don't bill Cosby
[inaudible] attribute that
we have a guy who we're working with
named Joe. Mandy is bizarrely genius.
I think Sasha was one of the funniest guy.
I mean,
Garry Shandling is brilliant to me.
Like the Larry Sanders show,
I think in a lot of ways,
does a lot of the stuff that a lot
of people try to do today. There's a,
there's an animator who I think and
writer who I think was one of the greatest
geniuses to ever live named
Don Hertzfeld and he's amazing.
He made this thing called rejected.
That is the funniest thing I think I may
have ever seen in my entire life. He, he,
he animates by hand usually
with a 16 millimeter camera.
He just started using computers a
little, but, uh, it's, it's, he's really,
it's like stick figures literally,
and it's,
it's the most genius thing I've ever
seen. He's incredible. Um, and uh, yeah,
he's probably not as lauded as one
could be. I think he gets nominated for,
I think he won an Oscar action. Nevermind.
Fuck. It does a really good looking.
But uh, yeah, I mean I I
think like, uh, Matt, uh,
and tray of Southpark and book of Mormon
to me are like two of the funniest
humans ever created. Again,
Judd and I mean, who,
who is like,
like growing up I was really
into like SCTV like Martin short
and in the hall on SCTV
played on a loop in the hall.
The hall is like in the halls,
like very,
it was very influential on us and
we watched it a ton growing up.
I've seen every single episode.
Like,
I never will turn on an episode
and it's one, I haven't seen it.
You want to see what one that kind
of changed our lives, Shirley,
which is one of the strangest,
and they did this short,
I believe how sausage sausage is s.
H. I. R. L. I. N. G. It's a made up word.
But what was great about kids will
hold is how insane it was. And like,
and it was, and, and, and,
and at the time it didn't seem insane
because we watched it so much and it was
on so much as we got older and started
to make stuff, we realized like,
I don't think I could get that show
on air right now. It's so bonkers.
And the fact that they got to do whatever
they want it even though like two out
of the five times it was a big miss.
The other times it's just like they
nailed it because they got to do what they
really want it to in their hearts.
And like,
we've gotten to work with
Lauren Michaels and I've, uh,
I've got to be around them a bunch.
And like,
that's one of the things we
talked to him about the most.
Every time we're around him and he, and
he's very proud of the show, but he says,
I mean,
he's like,
the key to that show was letting those
guys do whatever they wanted and that was
it. He's like, that
was, that show was like,
they had to do all of it cause that's
how crazy it was. We also had a,
well also quickly, Mel Brooks was like
a huge thing. Laura is amazing. I mean,
he's not like no one is being
a writer by trade or anything,
but he's a very funny guy and like,
it's like the Steve jobs of columns
and it's unbelievable what he's done.
And like, he's someone that every time I
am around him, it's like, uh, it's, it's,
it's truly like an awe inspiring.
Just from being in Canada,
we had a lot of British television,
so we got a lot of those like
Fawlty towers and Monte Python.
That gave us like a, uh, an attitude
towards comedy, that Ab Fab.
Did you watch that growing up? My
Mom, absolutely fabulous. Yeah.
My parents were really into comedy and
watched a lot of woody Allen movies when
I was growing up and like,
uh,
are there needs late bloomers in comedy
writing who has not say known since they
were kids that they want it to be in
comedy or in writing who have kind of come
onto the scene and done well that come
to mind. I mean that come to mind.
There must be, there must be. I mean it's
a tough question but it's a good one.
I can't think of anyone. More
comedy directing, acting Ferris.
Yeah, exactly. [inaudible]
funny. It's usually accidental.
Uh,
you
want a mosque on?
I can't, I can't think of any one of
those things though where it's like,
and, and I think it's what
brings comedians together.
It's so funny cause like whenever
you go, I don't, which I don't often,
but at the times I do go to
like a Hollywood type party.
All the comedians are often like lumped
together in one little section because
they often all know each other
and and their, and their,
and often they're the type,
they're similar types of people
for whatever bizarre reason,
known some things and little kids and
they want to be a comedian buttoned down
and this is maybe overgeneralizing
but they comedians know that life is
ridiculous and I think that's like a
common bond that holds them all together.
Well,
they're never going to figure this out.
This is all absurd and let's kind
of analyze how redundant a party.
They're all the people who want to stand
on the corner and make fun of the Party
and so they all, so they all go down and
then sometimes the whole Party is that.
Okay.
Brian Callan is a bit on the podcast
and buddy's a stand up comic.
He gave me my first tour
of the comedy store.
He's in the 40 year old
virgin movie doc off, right.
Oh,
which one
that Vicky is,
I could be wrong,
but he gave me my first tour at the
comedy store and the bunch of the comics,
she's ended up standing outside basically
making fun of the Party and shooting
the shit. But that's where the real comedy
is, is right outside the comedy club.
When you just think of it could
be more broadly outside of comedy,
like Evan, I'll ask you first, when
you think of the word successful,
who's the first person
who comes to mind for you?
Uh,
uh,
honestly my cousin David was that,
I got it.
I got two cousins,
David and Charlie who live in Orange
County and they just have a really nice
note life in three or two great kids.
And every time I go to their house,
I think this is the most successful group
of people I know just because they're,
they're really happy and they
all really like each other.
And it's rare to have a family that
everyone likes everyone and they're all
proud of each other.
So corny answer,
but my cousins date more people aren't
like that or don't have that. Um,
I think they just made up their minds
and I think other people deliberate too
much. Like they were just like, he
was like, I'm a doctor. She was like,
I'm going to be a teacher.
We want to kids,
we're going to live there and we're going
to make the best of our lives and uh,
go to the beach whenever
we can. They just, like, I,
they seem to have cut through a lot of
the bullshit and made their lives very
simple in a beautiful way.
And,
and it's all about their kids and I dunno,
I just feel like they are
the most levelheaded people
I know who have stuff like
really figured out.
Okay.
What yourself,
when you got to say something emotional,
you're going to be Michael Jordan.
[inaudible].
Uh Huh. Uh, I don't know.
My parents I feel like seemed
pretty happy and uh, um,
yeah,
I definitely don't ascribe like
a financial meeting Jewish,
um, off the top of my head. Uh, yeah,
my parents were on a cruise
in Alaska right now eating.
They just sent me a picture of a meal
that entirely comprised of Tater tots and
beer.
So
I'd say they're doing
pretty well right now.
His Dad has somehow made vegetarianism,
unhealthy,
unhealthy vegetarian on the entire planet.
But, uh, yeah, my parents were very,
very happy.
Be Honest, Lee and um,
and, and have always, uh,
I've always seen, they're very like,
they're pretty like Zen, I got to say,
which to me is like a, a
good, a good place to be.
And what I strive to be is, is
just a peace, a peace with myself.
Do you
Ooh, uh, Seth give books as
gifts ever? If so, I mean,
do you have a most gifted book
that you've given to people?
Um, I don't give books as gifts.
I give, I give some times like,
uh, like coffee table
type books as gifts. Um,
but like if someone's in a move, like
a, I like coffee table books, I'm not,
I read a, and I give comic
books sometimes to people.
I don't often give books to people
as gifts because I'm not myself,
like a huge retreat.
I'm not like,
have I given the people I've
given preacher to people,
I've given watchman to people.
I've used it.
I've given hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy to people. Cause I love that book.
And if they tell me they haven't read it,
I give that to them.
I've given this book the art of
dramatic writing to people cause it's
house.
That's,
that's something that John told us to
read book Judd gave us art of dramatic.
Yeah. If you're, if you're a writer,
60% of it's useless and
40% of it is references,
a lot of plays that if you haven't read
and you haven't because know who has it,
it just does it. A lot of it is
very referential in certain places.
The best part of is explains
the importance of premise
and how you must have a
rock solid one sentence,
premise or thesis
for the movie itself. Um, I
remember when Joe gave it to us,
he said it was woody Allen's
favorite writing book,
which was meaningful at the time. And
so, uh, I've given that book to people.
Um, the, the, that, uh, conquest
of happiness I've given to people.
Oh, that's a good book. That's
by Bertrand Russell Virtue.
It's like the original cell,
like the racial epitaphs. Yeah.
That's the time at the time
were more acceptable than it
all. Right. He was written in like 1920
or something like that, I think. Great.
But um, it's a, it's a great,
it's like one of the gee self
help books basically. Right. Um,
I think like the gist of the book is
like some say life is pleasurable,
some say it isn't.
So I think,
okay.
Um, and so, uh, I've given those
books to people. Yeah. But not a,
I don't give a ton of books to people.
I know we only have a little bit of time
left, but Evan, what, what about yourself?
Do you have him most uh,
every uh,
uh, new found? Every person who
becomes mother, who's a friend of mine,
I send this Canadian child's book love
you forever too, which I think is just,
bless you forever.
The number two or wherever it's a,
it's got a thing to love you forever.
Love you for always.
As long as you're living
my baby, you'll be, it's,
it's like a thing my mother and son and
I think that's a beautiful book that I
give to anyone. It's, but it's beautiful.
Yeah.
Unbelievably depressing. No one's
been upset. I gave it to them. Really?
That not to you?
A little bit.
A little prince is phenomenal
hitchhiker's guide and then I often give a
preacher v for vendetta
and the watchman to people.
But my main thing is love you forever.
I think that like anyone who has a
kid should have that book. No, we,
we were talking about
this briefly yesterday,
but could you describe the habit that
you picked up from Snoop Dogg? Um,
over the context. We were smoking
pot with snoop. What happened?
Did you pick up and,
and we were,
this is when we were recording that song
and we were hanging out with him and we
were smoking. You opposed
come in when you, right now,
yeah.
I can only write with hose around
and I don't know how we got to this,
but he was like,
you look to go for walks. I was like,
not really, I don't really. He's like,
what do you mean? I was like, oh,
I'll go for like exercise or whatever,
but I don't just go for walks.
And he looked at me really
disappointed and was like, you should,
you should go for walks, man. That's a
bad move. You're making a bad mistake.
And it haunted me that like snoop Dogg
was disappointed I can take walks.
So I started taking a walk in the
morning and a walk after dinner.
Eddie has massively changed my life. I
sleep better. I have a better day because,
and I just walked for like 10 minutes,
but he just kind of went
on like a little mini rant,
Sang Lik walking's great man. It's,
it's important. I walk with my kids,
walk people like having dogs. Yeah.
Yeah. Steve Jobs was a famous walker.
I'm not joking. He was known for
like doing meetings on walks.
Like instead of like sitting in a
office doing a meeting, he would,
they would walk around and now started
to, I become obsessed with, like I,
I will stretch during meetings and I
don't care who it's with. I will as,
as with you, I will stand
for full meetings because
I don't like sitting and a,
we're trying to get a new
office and when we do,
I'm putting a treadmill in there,
a bunch of other stuff.
Cause when we're writing I'm often
just like walking around the room.
Like I it in a pencil in my hand, try
a treadmill desk on. My friend has it.
It takes a little while to get used to,
but I don't think I could do that.
I've heard it.
I've heard it's good.
I saw someone running on a treadmill
reading a book at the gym this morning.
It sounds like no one's written
a hilarious joke on a treadmill.
That's never happened to me.
I have,
I have an elevating desk that goes up
and down, but I will try the treadmill.
What? Uh, yeah, the key is not running.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And
having a safety safety
clip on it. Uh, if, uh, if you
could have given your seats,
this is a 25 year old self, some
advice, what would you have?
What would you have said?
I would have told myself to lose weight,
no earlier
slots, like 25 pounds. And I feel so much
better and my brain is so much sharper.
And I was just,
I wasn't like massively overweight,
but I was overweight for those
from 25 to 31 and that was a very,
very big mistake.
That was very fixable and I wished that
I could go back in time and be like,
just start walking. You start walking them
nice walk. So we'll fix this all. And,
and uh,
and I found out I was allergic to wheat
so I wish I could go back in time and
tell myself,
cause I found that out three years
we go.
And if I found that out six years ago,
I would have had a lot better of a decade
about yourself. So I don't know. I was,
I was probably a lot healthier when I was,
I was really doing better by all beads
when I was 25 that I have right now. Um,
I probably would have told
myself to propose to my wife
sooner. Oh yeah, me too.
That would have saved me. And
why is that? Just cause I waited.
I waited like seven, six, six, nine.
I don't know. Probably not. But uh, it was
probably like a, what do they call that?
Enabling?
I think we probably enabled each other,
but I don't know,
I mean I don't have any like major
regrets that have occurred between now and
then or any like,
I think there's lessons I've learned,
but they've been valuable and
organic to my living process. Uh,
but the proposal I should've
proposed sooner that,
that I would have done differently.
Uh, this could be a set,
maybe a similar type of question,
but for you haven't,
if you could have one billboard anywhere
that said anything, what would it,
what would be on it? Ooh. Um, uh,
I've had a lot of billboards,
so [inaudible] you have a child.
Exactly. Whatever knocked out when
I, before coming out, November 24,
I guess my biggest beef with the world
that I would throw up on a billboard is,
uh, this, this is going to get deep
guys. No, except each other. Oh,
Evan Uhmm. I don't accept that. I don't
like when people don't accept one another.
I think they should and I would put it
on top of the empire state building.
Really?
People wouldn't see it very well.
Well, okay, fine.
She way to the Empire State building, uh,
accepting each other's good. I like that.
Except each other or just
meet with a picture of me
except
Seth Rogen. Well, I uh, I know we're,
we're wrapping up here.
You guys have a lot to do.
A little 11 more minutes tomorrow.
In that case,
I would like to, when we leave
we have to go back to our jobs.
Postpone that a little bit to
ask a couple of fan questions.
This one is from Kyle Bailey.
Uh,
he wants to know about the future
of comedy and this is what he says.
[inaudible] string theory.
What is funny on one side of the universe
creates a funny reaction on the other
side.
No one knows why.
He says,
it seems to me that late seventies
and then 80 satire Saturday night live
Seinfeld has led to all things funny.
That has led to all things funny being
absurd. Hence old spice commercials.
Having mandatory so on
seems like the more absurd,
the funnier at least in the mainstream
when will the snap back or when will we
experienced in the next direction of
comedy or is absurdity of the final act of
comedy and then somebody added to that
specifically on not online where you're
trying to grab attention,
distract.
I heard actually with
marketing specifically recently
someone told me that uh,
that now commercials like actually do
better if they make no sense like that.
Literally just like mountain
dew commercial. Have you
guys seen that mountain?
Like the horse and the one where it's
like this horse a tell you like there's
literally like I,
someone was explaining to me the theory
where it's like the fact that they make
no sense actually makes you
pay more attention to them
then a than a traditional
commercial narrative. I actually don't
necessarily agree with that. Yeah,
I got a degree. It's not absurd.
Transparent. It's not absurd.
Train wreck is one of the biggest comedies
of the year and it's like completely,
you know, a us, you know,
a very grounded movie.
Like we love ourselves and absurd comedy.
But Ethan,
both neighbors is our most successful
movie. And then a lot of ways it goes,
it's quite broad at times,
but in premise it's,
it's about people who have a bunch
of kids move in next door to them.
Like it's not that bizarre,
you know? So I actually think,
I think the biggest comedies are,
and are not absurd there.
There's somewhat grounded in reality and,
and the less th the somewhat popular but
maybe less popular comedy, he's like,
this is the end was,
did very well.
But isn't it the same universe as like
neighbors or train wreck is doing much
better than that?
Like I think those truly absurd ones I
actually don't do as well as the more
grounded one.
Well, it's like, you know, I'm
a mental, I mean I, not absurd,
but it's so it's confusing to so many
people. I mean, I love Memento, but uh,
but it's been set a kind
of disheartening to,
to find that a lot of my favorite
movies did very, very, very good.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Oh wait.
We always say this will never
be number one. And if we are,
we won't be that cool
anymore. Yeah, it's true.
Like we always will have the sense of
really where it's like things everyone
loves, I hate and things everyone
ate. I love. And I'm just, I,
and I don't mean that in like a, I'm not
trying to be like a hipster. And I do,
I also love a lot of mainstream stuff.
And like I'm the first guy in line
to see a Michael Bay movie. But fast,
fast and furious is the greatest
time you could have it in a bag.
But that being said, like there's
some shows that are really popular.
I'm just like,
I don't understand why people like this
and there's some shows that no one likes.
And I'm like, I don't call why people
don't love this, you know? And,
and as long as you have that sensibility,
I think there's a good chance you will
not be the most successful person.
I mean, it's along those lines. It's of
freaks and Geeks. Looking back at that,
I mean, what, and this is a question
from nick, nick, a breakthrough. Uh,
what was it about freaks and
Geeks at the made so successful
in their later careers?
Is that a,
would you attribute to advice they
received or more of a networking effect or
otherwise?
I'm paraphrasing but
I think honestly,
I mean my hope is that that judge just,
and Paul found people who
happened to me very talented and,
and I had the talent to sustain themselves
and then they cast very well. Yeah,
I think they cast very well.
And I like having cast movies with Judd.
Like he's just got the iron man.
He's very good at seeing is it just
an instinctual thing or is there,
is there some that you get better at it,
it's literally just,
there's not that many really funny people.
And like when you see someone who's
actually very funny like, and if you're,
it's again when we, you know, you talk
about it with investments, it's the exact,
like you start to hone in on just like
things that for whatever reason you start
to think like this is good.
Like, and I think you,
you can train yourself to become
more and more in tune with it.
And I think that's one of the things
Judd taught us is like keep your eyes out
for that person.
If you're watching a movie and someone
is in one scene and it has one line and
is funny, that person could star in
a home movie one day maybe. Yeah.
In the first neighbors there's this
standup drug Carmichael who's in it and he
now has his own show and we're trying
to write a movie a with our guys Kaolin
reo for him to start it. And it all just
came from our uh, coworker Alex saying,
I saw this guy and he's,
he's got it.
Yeah, look, look yourself
like a cat. And I think that,
I think more than anything, that's what
it is, is that they, he has a very good,
you know, Paul and Jack both have very
good eyes for spotting people that we'll,
that we'll keep working on.
Another thing is,
um,
they look long and hard.
Like when we were looking for who is
going to be the MC Loven Fogel character
and super bad, it literally came down
to putting up signs in high schools.
Allison Jones, the casting
director, did an epic search,
literally just putting up signs. Does
anyone know anyone who fits this bill?
And his buddies were like, you should go
do this. And we saw like, I don't know,
a hundred kids and that's
just what we saw. A, you know,
a filtered from the casting
director onto us. And, and, and,
and it's like a Hollywood cliche almost,
but when you see that person,
you go get him. That's the one. Yeah.
So just on Vic loving, because this,
this came up surprisingly
often. Uh, Justin,
uh, nine of Basti I think.
And then den Gmo designs,
I'm not sure I ask them if they,
if they would ever be willing to make
a spin off movie about Nick Levin.
We are not. But we have discussed, which
we'll never do. What am I about to say?
But we always thought it would be funny
to kind of do something where you take
Saul from pineapple,
express the James Franco character and
Mcclellan from Superbad and put them in a
movie together,
but it's never happened.
So why would you never do it in the
same way that Donald Trump thinks,
if he changes his hair, he'll ruin his
career to us. Like super bad worked.
It was everything we ever hoped it would
be and more. And I'm not touching it.
I'm not.
It's like if you throw two bulls
eyes and you're like, no, no,
don't was actually the best the way I
made a sequel to super bad and it was bad.
It would crush me. Exactly.
Yeah. I don't want to mess with,
I couldn't deal with that. Does a, it's
of course we'd comes up a lot. Uh, eat.
What's that?
The marriage you want to do you find
it helps creativity, productivity.
Neither. Both. I mean,
because there are questions about like
how do you be youth for you two guys? One,
what impact does it have that it makes
you a little dumber while you're on it.
But for us, uh, you know, no matter what
job you have, no matter how amazing it is,
it's work and work in some ways sucks.
And what we've tried to do at our office,
like we have a big buck hunter in our
office and just taking five minutes and
playing around a big buck hunter.
It like lets you chill out,
going for a little walk to get
a cup of coffee. Well it's been,
and for us and for some people
it's a very, very bad idea.
I would say like most people,
it makes them look so much worse that they
shouldn't. But some people it relaxes.
I think what's important,
I think why it's helpful to us is because
it's what we do socially and and so it
makes work not feel like work.
And I was,
I was actually just like yesterday
reading this thing that Isaac,
like it was an old article,
but Isaac Asimov wrote about the creative
process that was just republished.
And one of the things he talks a
lot about is, is in his process,
how it's very important to create
like a casual environment. And it,
he says like you shouldn't
work in an office.
You should work in someone's living
room or at a restaurant and you should.
And you need people who are jovial,
who so you can create a fun environment
because a lot of writing is failure.
And if you're self conscious
that you're going to be rejected,
then you won't say your best
ideas. And, and I think again,
if it's, I think our thing happens to be
smoking weed with some people. It's, it's,
it's other things.
But I think because it makes how
we're working feel like a not working
environment.
It makes our brains function
in a slightly more free way.
And it makes us pitch ideas that maybe
we would feel we're too stupid to pitch
if we were in a more rigid environment
and it would make ideas like this is the
end not exist,
not because were stoned but because we
are working in an environment that feels
very safe and that feels very
social and casual and that,
um,
and,
and that lets us pitch out the ideas that
might seem like the craziest ideas you
could ever pitch out.
But because we don't feel like we're
in a work environment where everyone's
judging us and that we're
wasting time or not, you know,
hitting the numbers are quotas that we
have to be hitting it. It allows us,
I think to be more free creative.
Yeah. Like in our office right now,
Seth has a bunch of paintings that he's
bought over the years from home and he
put them around and it feels like home.
That's what I like.
And I had like my yoga blocks and my
yoga straps and doing the stretches to me
is, is akin to the smoking pot,
which is like the best, uh,
Caucasian squat
does.
I've ever seen it
state.
He doesn't have the sitting position.
Usually it goes from straight standing
to perfect as in Japan that we call it
[inaudible] is the shit squad.
Yeah.
Well it's what they call and tell him
what you bought me like a platform that
goes around his toilet
so he can squat shit.
There's one thing people listening to
this should take from this podcast. It's,
you should be squatting when you shit,
it's natural. It's better for you.
It's bad for your back, it's bad for your
bowels and sit on a toilet, pop a squat.
What do you guys use, and I feel
like since you guys grew up in uh,
in BC that it's a for that is to pot as
like growing up in France would be to
wine. Is there a particular
type of politics? I've had
friends be like, no man,
you get anxious because of this.
You're using the wrong thing.
Those friends or possibly correct.
Um,
I had somebody who was telling me
the pots too strong. I don't like it.
It makes me anxious. So I went to one
of the stories in California and said,
can you give me some pot from 1995?
And they did and I gave it to the
person and they were like, there you go.
It goes by as strong as
the weakest link.
What is the absolute worst weed you could
buy now is what the best read was when
we were in high school.
Probably you can,
we have a problem where people will
smoke pot with us and we'll be like,
take it easy. We don't smoke
week stuff. We continued smoking.
Good read. But to get
name specific, uh, uh,
Jack Hair. Yeah, he is a good working one.
There's also good ones for
work and ones that very simple.
There's sativas and indicas and sativas
are genuinely kind of uppers and indicas
are genuinely kind of downers.
And when you're working a
sativas generally better
because it's not bogging you
down.
Jack has e h e r r.
E. R. H. E. R. R. I think
there's one are in the middle.
But yeah.
Is there a, do you guys have any, uh,
just in closing ask or recommendation
of the people listening?
Um,
I would say the,
the reason that this podcast is
happening right now is because, uh,
with that guy don hurts felt,
I mentioned there was one day where
I'm sitting there, I was like, God,
what I would do to talk to him.
And then I just picked up the phone
and called my agent and was like,
can you get me don hurts fillets number.
And I talked to him and it blew my mind.
And then I had the same thing
with a, this guy, Sam Harris,
who I look up to very much and
I look up and I just called him.
And so I reached out to you in the same
way and you write about this in your
book as well.
And I just think if you idolize someone
or you look up to someone or you respect
someone's work, try to get in touch with
them, it's, there's no harm. And so far,
I'm three for three and I have
an advantageous position. Yeah.
With an agent and all of that
incredibly successful producer, writer,
director there.
There's like a,
there's some guy a named Jordan who I
ran into on the street who I email with
and he now works at funny or,
and I keep them in mind and I
don't know this guy from anything.
He just came up to me one day on
the street and it's worth a shot.
You never know. Well, this Jordan
Guy could kill me one. Yeah.
[inaudible]
but uh, no, it's so true.
I mean some fans of mine,
if you reached out to Warren Buffet and
getting handwritten letters back from
them, you just never know.
Yeah. Well it's the same thing.
Like sometimes like Seth and
I always talk about this,
we'll find ourselves doing like an
interview or something and we look at each
other. We're like, why are we, when did
we agree to this? Why would we do this?
Sometimes people just drop
their guards and agree to shit.
They should. Exactly. That's like
a wink wink at me at the moment.
I've been at whole movies.
I don't understand why
you called the person on the one day where
there will is exhausted from whatever
else
and they're just like,
yeah man,
I'll meet with you as long as I can get
off this phone call right now. Yeah.
That's what I think too is just
just do it. I mean like Nike,
you meet so many people, Nike, I mean
Nike has the best tagline of all time,
but it's like we show when people talk
about writing movies and we did write a
movie and like,
you know,
my wife wanted to make a movie and so
she raised $1 billion and made a movie.
Like it's not something that
is completely unachievable.
It's something that if you are somewhat
talented and have a lot of determination
and are willing to put yourself
out there and are willing to fail,
then you can probably do
something more than nothing.
Neon Superbad was a success,
but like make no mistake for 10 years,
it was a failure and the
first five drafts, like if
you read them, you'd be like,
this is the worst thing
I've ever read in my life.
Let's over and over and over again.
Like,
I don't think anyone's gonna make this
movie. I don't think it was gonna be,
it was really, and like, it literally
didn't even occur to us to listen to them.
Like it wasn't even a conversation of
like, should we stop? Like, I literally,
we didn't even have that conversation
and was like, fuck those people.
Let's go to the next one.
You know,
Blake like to picture like
Stephen King writing his first
looking at me like, man, I'm
stumped. I'm going to go,
I'm going to go be something else.
Can you just keep going
blind belief in yourself?
Like it was turned down 26 or 27 times
also, I mean viciously like violently.
I have these like angry
sort of infuriated,
insulted letters from acquiring it
or just turn it down. All right guys.
Well let's, uh, I really
appreciate all the time.
Let's wrap up and we can do that with
telling people where they can find more
about you guys, find you on
the social webs and so on.
If they want to say hi, we,
uh,
due to a film called the [inaudible]
interview, we're not as active
on, we used to be pretty active.
Uh, I'm muck about on Twitter, a litter
a little in your Evan Goldberg. I'm,
I'm Evan Goldberg,
editor of Andy Goldberg or Evan.
I think it's just having to go over
just having goals for while. I will,
I will put it in the show notes
for everybody. Also, I'm Rogan on
Twitter and that's Rogan
with an ear or with an e.
If you,
if you write a letter and put it under
the second o in the Hollywood sign or the
second l in the Hollywood sign.
Go up there.
All right guys. Well thanks so much for
taking the time. I really appreciate it.
Everybody listening.
Of course.
Thank you for listening as always and for
all the show notes and everything else.
You can go to four hour
workweek.com spelled out.
Just click on podcast and until next
time, thanks for listening. Thanks guys.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour workweek.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by
Athletic Greens. I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day, and you can get 50 oh my
gosh, 50% off. Yes, 50% off.
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward
slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim check it out.
It's tasty but more important it will
help you not screw up when you're doing
your nutritional plannings.
So for me it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo
pro, which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact,
a bunch of my startups already use Vimeo
pro including wealth front who uses it
to explain how wealth
front works task grab,
it uses it to tell the company story and
there are many other names that you'd
recognize among their customers, airbnb,
Etsy, et cetera. Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level
video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost. Features include gorgeous
high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of
video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and they
fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro, et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get
all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated
bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
demio.com forward slash business that's
[inaudible] dot com forward slash
business and use Promo
Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just
for you guys. So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash
business promocode tip.
You want more of the Tim Ferriss show?
You can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes
or go to for our blog.com Fou r h o U
R B l o g.com where you'll
find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video
interview stories with people.